d-class personnel are the cogs that keep
the machinery of the scp foundation
running smoothly unfortunately things
are rarely very smooth for the personnel
themselves there's a reason that common
knowledge basically states that d stands
for disposable the lab rats of the scp
foundation d-class is a role that no one
in their right mind wants to play but
what if you didn't have a choice what if
somehow whether through a shift in time
and space or being accused of a crime
you didn't commit you've found yourself
transported to a cell at an scp
foundation site once there you quickly
realize how dire your situation is
but there's hope maybe you overhear your
fellow inmates whispering about other
prisoners who managed to escape could
you use your knowledge of the scp
foundation to find your way back to
freedom we posed this scenario and
questioned to the amazing fans of scp
explained and you told us about all the
ways you would try to escape from the
scp foundation before your inevitable
termination or worse transmutation so
let's get right to it and see who would
make it out and who would wind up in
scp-682's stomach just drake said well
considering i've quite enjoyed the vr
game scp lab rat i'd wait for a good
containment breach maybe release a few
extra scps that may be contained with me
trust no voice i hear looking at you as
cp 939 and just make for some type of
hull created or maybe sewage strain i've
never beaten the game truthfully but
it'd be an adventure video games are the
best way to prepare for real life
everyone knows that that's why resident
evil made me great at killing monsters
animal crossing made me a world class
fisherman and the sims prepared me for
those days where the door to my room is
suddenly replaced with a painting of a
clown really though that sounds like a
solid strategy use the chaos of a
containment breach as a cover play robin
hood to some friendly scps don't follow
any voices and see if you can shawshank
redemption your way to freedom what have
you got to lose well maybe your life but
you probably wouldn't hold on to that
for long at the foundation anyway unwind
said easy peasy having a leg up is an
understatement in this situation having
watched scp-explained videos we have a
great understanding about the foundation
and the scps even more so than the site
director themselves just claimed to be
an o5 council member from a parallel
universe and when interrogated dropped
some classified information only they
would know you'd be such a valuable
resource they might even let you join
their council not only have you escaped
d-class duties you've also gained high
amounts of power easy peasy indeed just
make an incredibly bold claim and expose
yourself as a potential security risk
there's a slim chance this might work
but there's also a pretty substantial
chance that the real o5 council will
intervene and decide to go ahead and
terminate you just in case at the very
least you'd likely be placed in
permanent protective custody but hey
maybe they'll put you in one of the
comfy cells with a minibar and
everything gaming revelation said if i
was escaping i would use an audio clip
of 682 screaming and or destroying
things and play it when people or scps
are nearby the sounds of 682 will scare
people away or make a good enough
distraction for any guard stupid enough
to fight 682 i would also email the
audio file to myself that way i can use
the audio file on basically any device
this is an interesting one you need a
lot of factors to line up just right for
this one to work from keeping your phone
or another device on your person in
spite of being in foundation custody to
finding a wifi signal to access your
email to making sure that your audio
file plays loudly enough to be
convincing not sure what they have
planned for the next update but
currently the iphone doesn't emit sounds
at a volume loud enough to break through
walls there is a chance that the sound
would strike enough fear into the hearts
of experienced guards to throw them off
for a while anyway just make sure
scp-682 doesn't find out what you're up
to it probably doesn't appreciate
copycats ender titan games said i have a
pretty simple but solid escape plan i
think step 1 find out what site i'm at
what kind of scps are contained there
are they dangerous or harmless how often
are their containment breaches how often
do d-class die if the sites seem safe
enough then i'll just spend my days
meeting harmless scps like 999 step 2 if
the site is dangerous then i need to do
everything in my power to make sure i'm
not cross tested with a dangerous scp if
that means stabbing my eye out or
cutting off my leg i'll do it i'll do
anything short of killing myself if it
keeps me away from the likes of 106 and
682 step 3 try and see if any of the
scps could help me escape for instance
if 738 is at the site then i'll find a
way to get cross-tested with it and then
ask to be free from the foundation and
have all my criminal records wipe sure
it'll cost me but hey at least i'll be
free or i could find a ketter class scp
and see if we could help each other
break out it's a risky option but once
again i do everything in my power to
stay away from the lizard step four if
all else fails then i'm either going to
have to wait for or cause a massive
containment breach then i can escape in
the confusion all that time playing scp
secret lab will come in handy once again
it's a risky option and i don't really
like my odds but i'll take my chances if
i have to step 5 if i die and let's be
honest i most likely will then i only
have two requests for the foundation one
that they actually decide which scp-001
is the real
scp-001 and two that my tombstone read
subscribe to scp explained because they
make fun and entertaining videos also
screw the lizard first of all this isn't
a simple plan by any means it's not a
canadian rock band formed in 1999 and
it's actually got quite a lot of detail
you've thought long and hard about this
and we appreciate that one note though
making a deal with scp-738 might not
just cost you a previous d-class was
offered freedom by the entity at the
cost of his best friend's death even
after he took that deal with the devil
he was recaptured by the foundation a
mere five hours later you can decide for
yourself if that's really worth it but
hey if you're that desperate then go
right ahead at least you've prepared for
the very worst the first of your
posthumous requests will likely be
denied if we're being honest and the
second request is very sweet of you look
i'm blushing but also we'd prefer if you
didn't put a foundation target on our
backs by pointing out how many of their
secrets were revealing you're right
about one thing though can't stand that
lizard juan torres said we're going to
need a teddy bear an aluminum coated box
a chair and a desk an intact human
nervous system a dart gun and lawn mulch
wait wait don't stop there you're just
going to give us a list of ingredients
and not finish the recipe i already went
out and bought all that stuff and the
nervous system won't stay fresh forever
super hamsters said plug 079 into the
wi-fi it could cause a breach big enough
so hide during the breach and then
escape the ruined facility let me
explain further 682 and 079 bonded and
682 is famous for containment breaches
682 is very hard to recontain so if you
help 079 he'll help 682 which will help
you also many other dangerous scps will
be breached now this is thinking big
sure you'll be exposing the entirety of
the world wide web to an aggressive
unpredictable and downright rude
artificial intelligence but you'll
probably be able to escape back into the
world who knows how much of the world
will actually be left after you've
unleashed 079 682 and a whole host of
other dangerous anomalies but the
remaining rubble will be your oyster
creature savage said assuming i'm at a
site with an intelligent scp that's
known for escapes such as 682 i'd offer
it a chance at freedom if it helped me
escape and we'd both take off for the
infinite ikea of course i could also
offer ferdinand the cannibal my services
as a jester for his protection all the
way to and through the infinite ikea
fernand the cannibal now you're talking
if you manage to team up with that
gargantuan gentleman he could definitely
be a big help just make sure he stays
well fed or your new friend is going to
start wondering how you taste with fava
beans and a nice chianti otherwise
though he'd love to have someone listen
to his stories and take the high part
during his favorite songs once you're
free though why not shoot for the stars
no need to fend off the murderous staff
of the infinite ikea just go to a
regular ikea and get a new couch and
some meatballs no monsters necessary
delay animation said before escaping
there are multiple problems to overcome
you have to know the layout guards
patrol paths camera placement which key
cards you need which opportunities are
best to escape and once you manage to
find all of that out and escape the
outside you're still not done depending
on if you were in a site or area the
bare wilderness surrounding a site would
be enough to wreak havoc on you not to
mention the watchtowers and outside
patrols if you were in an area the
foundation would most likely have agents
in the town surrounding the area in
conclusion it is not possible to escape
the foundation's grasp the only way to
not wind up as a class d is to not do
anything to become a class d you know
what they say the best defense is a good
offense an ounce of prevention is worth
a pound of cure however there's not much
offense or prevention you can do when a
temporal anomaly thrusts you into a
parallel universe and plops you down
right in the middle of a d-class cell so
even if you keep your hands clean your
entire life you might just
don't work like that zagham shabazz
kareem said the best thing to do is to
make allies first of all you need to get
as many d-class personnel on your side
as possible ask them what duties they
are on and use your information to help
them also use them to find out what your
duties are going to be as they will have
connections you need to stay on the down
low as if you're found out you'll be
experimented on or worse but you don't
only want to make allies with the
d-class armed with the knowledge from
scp explained you are able to guess or
approximate which facility you're at
what scps might be there and who the
staff are with that knowledge you can
approach some of the kinder staff and
build your relationship so in case you
get caught when escaping you have a
fallback or someone that can bail you
out of deadly punishments you also want
to be resourceful and map out the place
to identify escape routes and the armory
or weapon storage facility next you want
to form better relationships with some
of the scps before terminations roll
around you want to arrange a day that
the d-class personnel helps them as cps
out of containment most non-deadly ones
as you don't want to make an enemy out
of the scp foundation but enough to
distract the guarding personnel also
with your close contact with facility
members you have a better chance at
stealing credentials or passes to allow
yourself through doors and escape but
that isn't all there actually might be
some scps on site that will make
escaping easier and your goals should
not just be your own escape but escaping
with as many d-class personnel as
possible you want to equip them with
passes all of them should know only one
specific escape routes which they
themselves or a few others are going so
that even if they are caught the others
will not be found out then you want a
few of them to escape before everyone
else and cause a ruckus outside making
it look like the whole group has escaped
sending guards behind them they'll need
access to a vehicle so that needs to be
secured from one of the staff which
could be captured during the escape and
used for a way out or you could steal
their keys earlier depending on the
situation you yourself and a few others
head to the armory to secure weapons not
only to escape but to protect yourself
from scps in the future then you need to
secure vehicles for the group which you
will need to put distance between the
facility and your group and stay away
from other nearby facilities you'll need
to stop at a certain point and go to the
nearest hospital to check for body
implants or anything that can be used to
track you changing clothes and
continuing on by foot at this point your
group can choose to separate live
collectively and stay alert of the
foundation or join another organization
this is probably the longest response we
received we just had to include it to
applaud the dedication and thought at
play here as well as the selflessness
you're not just planning for your own
rescue now that's too small time for
zakim you're planning to liberate every
d-class you can and potentially start
your own brand new society together make
sure you have a nice talk with them
about the rules for your new community
such as absolutely no stabbing your
neighbors and enjoy all the great
trauma-free barbecues that follow plot
armor said i would either attempt to
cause a containment breach or steal an
anomaly like scp-268
still first i would draw thelmaturgic
symbols all over my body in clothes like
kalpastan isle which will make me
resistant to physical damage that will
help me survive a containment breach
bringing thammaturgy into the equation
is a brilliant move you'd likely be the
only d-class on site with any knowledge
of that work or the symbols you'll have
to act fast though and work your magic
before the foundation figures out what
you're up to if you don't they'll likely
wipe your memory with amnestics or just
terminate you on the spot the trickiest
part of this plan is probably finding
something to write with you can't
exactly ask to borrow a pen but between
those and the hat you could probably
slip out unnoticed and unscathed jacob
otty said i just do my best to find mr
peanut so i could die relatively quickly
or painlessly why would that kill you
are you allergic just kidding we know
you're talking about scp-173
as bleak of an answer as this is we have
to commend your honesty and
self-awareness it takes to look at the
dangers of trying to escape the scp
foundation and simply saying
no i'd rather not just another person on
the internet said well taken with
someone who has a very short attention
span and who is a procrastinator with
adhd i could request a test with miss j
to see how it would affect someone like
me then i could escape and live the rest
of my life in peace and solidarity miss
j did help a previous d-class leave the
foundation behind and start a new life
so why not you too we're sure you'll be
a model pupil and wish you luck in
whatever discipline you decide to pursue
don't forget your number two pencil milo
knight said
scp-6113 is a pretty surefire way to get
out assuming you meet the criteria you
can suddenly have a different name and
appearance and you won't really be on
any foundation records use that to plead
your case just pray you don't get
terminated this would be a pretty
drastic choice and you'd probably have
to double down on the whole new life
thing since none of your loved ones will
recognize you or you can just tell them
you got extreme reconstructive surgery i
guess but it's better to be alive in a
new body than dead in your usual one as
long as you're able to avoid detection
following your transformation and make
sure they don't catch you on the
security tapes this might just work
zadanor0203
said i mean you can't yes you'll survive
until the monthly termination but with
how fortified these sites are unless you
can get lucky with a containment breach
or are able to gain access to the sewer
system you're not escaping and that's
not even taking into account your
spontaneous being here and having great
knowledge on the foundation that you'd
only really know if you were a being
above their perception so on top of that
there's also the potential of you being
terminated for knowing too much or being
contained as a new scp hey now we didn't
say reply with the best way to bum us
out really though we see all of your
hyper-realistic commenters and we get it
really but in a world filled with killer
statues and friendly slime monsters
anything is possible sure most of the
d-class that wind up behind foundation
walls wind up dead but you could be the
one in a million who makes it out dare
to dream matt's magic said easy i simply
say whoever shoots me or harms me is a
rotten egg and then walk out unharmed
due to the fact that guards are in fact
people not eggs that's it you've cracked
the code unless the scp foundation
starts hiring eggs as guards or creates
some sort of unholy human egg hybrid to
staff their halls we're looking at you
humans refuted their days of keeping
d-class prisoners are over thank you for
participating in yet another weird wild
community response video from scp
explained what's your favorite escape
attempt anything we missed let us know
down in the comments and if you want the
chance to be featured in the next one
keep an eye on our community tab for the
next question and in the meantime get
back in your cells now go check out your
questions for god answered and how to
actually beat
scp-3008 the infinite ikea for more
questions and answers from the
scp-explained community